dann sollten wir noch die frage stellen
wollt ihr den totalen krieg dann sollte
man diese frage stellen und ehrlich sein
zu den menschen und nicht gar nichts
sagen
[Musik]
die deutschen leitmedien sind so
derartig unterwandert das ist
wahrscheinlich bald krieg geben wird
also die deutschen leiten ideen sind
vielleicht von cia und obama und putin
meine damen und herren das soll mir doch
die bürger selber erklären was heißt
ehrliche und richtige presse also was
was fordern sie von der ehrlichen und
richtigen presse
das wissen sie doch fernsehen aber sie
kriegen ihre nachricht die vorher setzt
und sie selber in der suppe oder und er
sehr hinsehen ob sie selber könne ja
nicht berichterstatterin wird
vorhersehbar sind und dementsprechend
das habe ich einfach einzig objektive
berichterstattung von ard und zdf nicht
mehr an
schon lange aber woran nichts woran
liegt es einfach diese fremdgesteuert
fremdgesteuert von der regierung vor
steuern von fremden interessen und das
ist einfach der grund scheiße rundfunk
wir scheiße zu sagen die tagesschau
tagesthemen haben auch über ramstein
berichtet und was die drohnen einsätze
angeht zum beispiel selbst die bild
zeitung hat über die drohneneinsätze
rabenstein worden womit niveau so weit
runter gehen die bild -zeitung reden was
man lieber also das ist auch werk gegen
russland wettert ist ein nazi würden sie
so eine propaganda machen dann sind sie
natürlich würde ich meinen euro welches
kurze aber habe es habe kein problem
damit sie können sie gleich in einen
karton gepackt so klar ist ja so ich
frage mich schon warum brauchen gesunde
einseitige berichterstattung warum warum
muss man gegen ein land wetter physik
nicht eigentlich mehr für deutschland
getan hat als wieder an
was hat in russland jetzt irgendwie
gemacht also rom annektiert also ja aber
die boxen gesehen
boxen bugs und glitches schade war eine
reine vereine kriegs veranstaltungen des
rockers soll ja das war hätte ohne ende
gibt es eine liste wie beträge amerika
angefangen hat und wie will krieger irak
angefangen hat gibt es auch welche gibt
es eine liste wie viele träger russland
angefangen hat das weiß ich nicht das
ist mir auch egal
normal sind herrn kinogänger noch mal
sagen ich mir interessiert mich alles
nicht
das eintreten in deutschland will dann
sollte man noch die frage stellen wollt
ihr den totalen krieg dann sollte man
diese frage stellen und ehrlich sein zu
den menschen und nicht gar nichts sagen
und einfach so tun als wenn es das nicht
gibt als wenn es das hier alles nicht
gibt laut das nicht seit wochen so in
deutschland dann in den städten leipzig
und dresden in berlin
irgendwo stehen leute und guckt euch
doch damit gewichts weg zu meinem
freundeskreis als träger nach köln
da kannst du drei wieder löschen und
ähnlich gesendet